[Musique]
le prix de l'essence
aujourd'hui en france a pris 50 centimes
l'état est en train de gagner beaucoup
d'argent sur cette hausse du pétrole et
moi je suis favorable à une baisse des
taxes parce qu'elle est simple parce
qu'elle est rapide et elle doit
également rester provisoire le temps que
les prix du carburant flambe si le
gouvernement veut vraiment apaisé les
angoisses des français et ce prélèvement
très violent sur le pouvoir d'achat il
baisse les taxes certains nous disent il
faut impérativement baisser les taxes
sur le carburant je crois pas que ce
soit la bonne option d'abord parce que
ça coûte très cher un centime de baisse
du litre de carburant c'est un demi
milliard d'euros vous voyez bien que
c'est très coûteux pour un résultat que
les français ne verront pas ça va être
un chèque carburant c'est ça la piste la
piste c'est plutôt ça c'est plutôt ça
après sous quelle forme je ne sais pas
encore parce qu'on essaye de trouver le
moyen qui nous permet de toucher les
bonnes personnes
baisse des taxes
donc de l'argent au moins dans les
caisses de l'état oui mais vous savez au
point où on en est au point emmanuel
macron à jeter l'argent par les fenêtres
pendant le coc vide c'est une question
de réactivité et de prise de conscience
de la détresse qui va monter et du et
d'une d'une bombe sociale à retardement
vraiment mais on l'a connu avec les
gilets jaunes on va pas commencer à
fermer les yeux nous devons désormais
l'affirmer de façon claire le modèle à
l'ancienne du pavillon avec jardin dont
on peut faire le tour n'est plus
soutenable et nous mène à une impasse il
faut donc l'affirmer le partage et l
expliquer cet idéal n'est plus
soutenable qu'est ce qu'elle préfère si
on interdit la maison individuelle a de
quoi faire le logement collectif ce
qu'elle appelle regardez bien aussi ce
summum de novlangue elle appelle ça
l'intensité heureuse c'est totalement
orwelliens comme vocabulaire l'intensité
heureuse je ne suis pas du tout opposé à
la maison individuelle ni celle
d'aujourd'hui ni celle de demain la
question c'est simplement de savoir où
et comment on construit et oui j'habite
dans une maison à s'arranger en plus
dans la banlieue cossue du vol une
maison de 150 mètres carrés estimé à un
million et demi d'euros quand vous
plutôt deux voire plus selon les
spécialistes faites ce que je dis pas ce
que je fais grains ce qui exhument même
une photo devant chez elle avec son
docteur de mari matthias wargon qui est
furieux de cet étalage intime et qu'il
le dit sur twitter faut pas venir me
faire chier je le cite ap jp a aussi des
mobilisations et à être devant les
préfectures pour demander aux préfets et
aux sous-préfets partout qu'il remonte
auprès du gouvernement la colère des
français leurs attentes à ce que des
factures baisse et à ce que des salaires
et des pensions augmente plusieurs
individus à moto s'adonne à un rodéo
urbain la scène est filmée par pierrot
l'hiver le maire du 2e arrondissement de
lyon place bellecour
les auteurs pourraient être les membres
du groupe de rap les dalton ils se sont
filmés en direct sur instagram eric
zemmour débute en politique
il doit aussi apprendre je pense
l'humilité l'extrême droite
traditionnellement france allah le sait
très bien c'est ce qu'ils veulent
renverser la république je rassure tout
le monde je ne veux pas renverser la
république nemorino kyste bas en
quelques semaines
vous voyez ça oui ce lundi matin sais
pas s'il faut vous savez le hoki ce
fondamentalement c'est de faire de
l'addition de vos frustrations de
discriminations ressenties aurel une
forme de de levier pour soutenir une
politique mais ça a presque fait examen
zeno fog c'est quelqu'un qui n'aime pas
les étrangers je rassure aussi moi je
n'ai rien contre les étrangers
simplement je préfère les français et
donc ce que je préfère c'est défendre
les français c'est la partie basse de la
tribune qui s'est affaissée alors qu'une
dizaine de supporters fêtaient la
victoire de leur équipe les joueurs
étaient venus saluer leurs fans juste en
bas de la tribune heureusement aucune
cima